sweetest pie by the way is already my
summer jam it's on heavy rotation i know
a lot of fans were dying for that
collaboration with you and meg how did
it come to be
um the collaborate it was really me and
meg were really going back and forth
talking to each other and we were just
we always wanted to do something
together but it just took us a little
bit of time to do it because we wanted
to figure out like the right track that
would work with both of us that also
felt new she's so great and wonderful
and i've loved working with her so it
was a real pleasure to get together and
do the song
this duo also channeled whitney houston
and mariah carey while presenting at the
grammys in matching versace
debuted a new look
i gotta say we loved the blonde hair at
the grammys thank you are you gonna have
some fun with the hair color this summer
like what's the vibe i don't know yet
because i know when you uh last went
blonde it was right before you released
don't start now so is that something
like fans should be reading into when
you change your hair color
um
maybe okay maybe we'll see we'll see
fingers crossed new music is on the
horizon but for now dua is on the road
in europe after performing for u.s fans
earlier this year i got a chance to see
the future nostalgia tour you absolutely
smashed it i could tell how much love
but also work went into it
and your choreo girl i swear
i mean how would you describe like the
dua lipa signature move and dancing like
how has it evolved
i mean it's evolved drastically i i
guess i really have like a full
choreography routine that happens
through the future nostalgia tour that i
didn't have before um so in that sense
it's it's a full-on like i like to just
describe it as like the traveling circus
it's just a lot of fun and the part that
makes it really exciting is the reaction
from the fans
also the fashion from the tour how much
fun has it been to kind of bring your
vision to life through everything not
just the music and the set list and the
choreography but also your style it was
so much fun you know that the show is
split up in four parts and being able to
to have um you know an outfit that
really fits the story of every single
part in the show is really exciting and
to create a whole world around that was
really special for me also special for
dua truly's poolside variety pack
inspired by the grammy award-winning pop
star with four new flavors for summer
what flavor what's your flavor i need to
know i really love the kiwi mojito
flavor of that one yeah
[Music]
your bio says you're a movie junkie
bookworm inquiring mind you obviously
have this new podcast i'm curious what
does the inquiring mind of dua lipa want
to learn about next through the podcast
i guess i guess the best answer to that
is i'm i don't really i'm not really
sure it's all about asking questions
understanding people i think that's all
i could ever hope for is just that my
curiosity would lead me to a better
understanding of the way that people are
so i can also i don't know be more
empathetic and understanding and feel
things in a different way
you